make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking back up again
with deceased with hope at world's end
now again this is the filler content
right this is the stuff that fills in
the main dc story and what we end up
doing here is actually picking up
with what looks like red hood in the
crew when they were escaping when they
were getting out of where all those kids
were but one of the kids was ultimately
left behind
right now the other part of this is that
it also focuses on detective chip i
almost called him beppo the super monkey
but it focuses on detective chimp and
the cool thing about detective champ he
is super smart right in a lot of ways um
but he's also like one of the world's
greatest detectives and
and we're not really given a lot of
context as to why he's here it's simply
just tom taylor picking up with him
being here right so we can just sort of
go with our own assumptions and just say
like he's trying to make his way like
everybody else why he would stop to
investigate you know
a broken uh a broken horse doesn't
really make a whole lot of sense i think
this is one of those instances where tom
taylor wanted to just just want to tell
a kind of story he just wanted to tell
it and
ultimately that's just kind of where we
are the idea here is that
detective chimp is basically
investigating this this broken horse and
then
seems to come to the realization you
know from just looking around that it
belonged to a little girl and that's
exactly what happened right this little
girl had dropped her horse and the horse
had broken she'd crawled down to get it
and when she did
the bus had left her now why she thought
it was a good idea to crawl away and
like go to a place where a bus wouldn't
be able to see her
in the midst of the world ending and
then believe everything would be okay
i don't know i'm not really sure suffice
it to say she's not very smart
but what it does is of course it leads
to basically one of the the anti-life
showing up and attacking her only for
ace the bat hound to basically come out
of nowhere now that's kind of the cool
thing because we sort of go back and
forth right and it can be a little
confusing at first glance but we
basically go back and forth it's one of
these scenarios where we have like
detective
telling us what seems to have happened
and then us having it confirmed through
the various story you know how the story
is being told by tom taylor but ace
immediately takes to the girl right and
that's the nature of ace the bad hound
right like he's a he's a hero right he's
a hero dog and it's cool because he's
one of these things that you don't
really get to see in dc comics all that
often which is sort of disappointing i
would read an ongoing
comic about like this like the super
pets oh my god especially if it had
captain carrot dude imagine that imagine
like captain carrot leading
all of the super pets captain carrot i
love captain carrot
captain carrots a super bunny i love him
carrots amazing but nonetheless like it
is a it is a cool little it's a cool
little moment here right like ace
basically saving her and then ultimately
it leads to detective chimp tracking
them down right and ace is initially
exceedingly hostile but then uh
detective champ starts talking to him
now this is one of the things that
detective chimp can do he can
communicate with other animals
regardless of their origins
and so he basically just starts talking
to ace and he's like you know he's like
i'm not here
to hurt the little girl and ace is like
you're not he's like no he's like okay
cool then we're cool man like we're
we're cool you know it's it's
interesting because as he goes through
and starts talking the question he's
asking her is are you going to the
garden in gotham city and that seems to
be why he was why he was here right he's
on his way to the garden inside of
gotham city now for
detective champ and this is kind of a
this is one of the interesting things
that i feel like would fly under the
radar while he is a detective
he is also a chimp and so his strength
exceeds that of an average person
you guys remember that story from like a
while ago when like some woman had a
chimpanzee as a pet
and like it ate her face and ripped her
hands off like just like insane stuff
like that right like if you guys have
ever seen that picture of a chimpanzee
when like all his fur was removed dude
those guys are
ripped dude they're they're huge
it's nuts how strong chimpanzees are i
didn't realize that you know he could
like take to the trees so there's
different ways for him to escape so on
the surface you might kind of look at it
like okay what how could a chimpanzee
have here but in reality it kind of
makes sense given the nature of his
character now this is all just kind of
unspoken by tom taylor but i kind of
like that right i like the kind that tom
taylor doesn't necessarily like hold
your hand and say okay so like this is
how detective
chimp made it so far and this is how
he'll make it to the garden like i like
that he doesn't really do that right and
so of course
this leads to detective chimp arriving
at the gotham equestrian center and the
reason why is because he's
as he's kind of thinking he's like okay
there's someone that we need to go talk
to
and we end up finding out that at the
time the anti-life virus
started to unfold basically started to
kind of expand out that you had comet
the super horse and comet the super
horse was of course with its owner now
comet
it's crazy i haven't seen comet in so
long here's a funny thing comet was
originally introduced in the old
supergirl stories and it was super
girl's super friend
superman had crypto she had comet and
then you had beppo the super monkey and
he had streaky the super cat that was
all part of more a part of mort
weissinger's like 10 year vision where
he's like add something new every six
months and who cares what it is and
people loved it they were just like yeah
man
like super animals
[Laughter]
that's basically what it was people
loved it right people thought it was the
coolest thing and so it ended up being
that when this this whole thing happened
of course the anti-life army immediately
sought upon
comet and this girl this girl ended up
falling off breaking her own back and
dying in the process and so it basically
just kind of leaves comment by herself
but
basically what this does is it leads to
the arrival of bad hound and it leads to
the arrival of of this young girl
so so as this is going on of course it's
kind of like this sort of consolidation
of these super friends but the other
cool thing here are the super pits the
other cool thing is like like bat hound
chimes in to detective chimp right he's
kind of sniffing in the air and chimp's
like hey man like do you
do you smell something and he's like
yeah man i smell death moving and it's
like okay come on amy like we gotta go
right little girl's name is amy it's
like we gotta go and they immediately
start bolting out of there now again
like bat hound can keep
up and that's fine but the the more they
run into the thick of these things the
more they run into all that
the more they basically end up being
attacked right more frequently and
frequently now it's actually kind of
funny because
detective chimp actually ends up getting
scratched but the reason why he's not
infected
is i'm not entirely sure how much i
agree with this the reason why he's not
really infected and he doesn't turn
is when he's asked by amy why is this
the case he says because the anti-life
equation is something that was dreamed
up by gods and gods don't really see
animals as sentient now the
dna of a chimpanzee in a human is not
that
far removed and and really the anti-life
equation isn't really concerned with dna
right it's not like it only looks out
for certain people with certain dna
markers instead it dominates individual
it dominates sentience right it
dominates the ability of
sentient beings to think for themselves
right basically turns them at least
that's how it normally functions with
this one it infects them and turns them
into mindless monsters but i would think
that
anything that has the ability to think
on some level of rational thought some
level of understanding or at least
communicate with other other beings
would in turn become mindless and even
if they couldn't communicate they would
just become a more angrier version of an
already mindless beast so this this
explanation
is kind of hand wavy to be honest it's
just kind of hand wavy and sort of throw
away but he also makes this funny
comment where he says if there really
was going to be some kind of virus that
was going to be spread throughout the
world the best way to do it would be to
in turn basically have it planted in
mosquitoes and have mosquitoes do things
and that now that i think about it that
actually does kind of make sense right
that does actually kind of make sense
because the whole reason the virus
spread was because of people using
things like technology right it was
because of cyborg the whole thing spread
right so using
you know smartphones computers different
things like that and i have a hard time
believing detective champ uses an apple
ipad
or like an iphone right like i don't
really think he does
[Laughter]
it'd be kind of funny if he did but i
guess that kind of makes sense in
irrational hindsight but even the way
the explanation is given is like even if
he did look at an iphone like he
wouldn't be infected because the
anti-life infection only infects like
humans right so even then
it still seems a little hand-wavy but
it's fine right i mean it's tom taylor
we grant him some measure of stuff like
that we're like uh you know with any
other writer it would be a problem with
tom taylor i really like him so it's
okay
that's that's really kind of how we are
as comic book fans but ultimately of
course they end up making it at least
within the city of gotham but the
problem with this
is that they're immediately set upon by
a whole host of these anti-life monsters
and literally are attacked from every
conceivable direction right like comet
comes crashing down uh you and i have
amy that flies off right you've got uh
detective shampoo goes flying and it's
just kind of like okay like like they're
effectively cornered and trapped right
there's really there really isn't
anywhere for them to go
and that's when there's a little bit of
a little bit of panicking going on
because then suddenly
you have bat hound out of nowhere who's
just who who literally just starts
barking
and detective chimp is like what what
like what are you saying and then like
he literally starts to howl and he's
like flying and he's like yeah man
and then like crypto comes out of
nowhere man here's the thing
dude okay here's the thing it's amazing
krypto literally swoops in and saves the
day it's the most crypto thing
that anybody could do right like crypto
the comment doc so here's the thing i
want to read a team up comic where like
crypto and the comet dog or crypto and
not the common dog crypto and
uh and bat hound like would they go on
adventures and of course like they're
talking to each other right like
they're communicating and so on and it's
like dude this is this is awesome man
it's like it's like super dog and bat
and bat dog like teaming up but it's
it's a cool thing here
because once you have crypto who's there
he literally clears the way for
everybody and it basically allows them
to enter inside the garden and then once
they're there they're basically safe now
here's the thing right this is this is
basically where it ends but here's the
thing i for real like when i when i when
i
like got this comic and i started
reading it i for real thought that like
tom taylor was gonna kill one of the
animals because that's one thing tom
taylor would do
right tom taylor would be like they make
it to the garden except for bad hound he
dies
like i feel like that's what would
happen like tom taylor would do
something like that right and
as people we're not okay with that we
don't care what you do to the people
every single human being on the face of
the earth could die in just some
horrible grizzly death
as long as the dogs are okay
it's how we are as people like i i don't
i don't feel bad about that
i don't feel bad about that they're dogs
they're amazing right dogs are awesome
they're they're they're cute and they're
cuddly and they're nice and they fly and
they shoot you with heat vision
like they're cool right and it's and
it's a it's a cool thing right so i'm
glad tom taylor didn't kill the pets
he didn't kill the super pets i for real
thought he was but let me know down in
the comments section right like would
you guys
read a team-up comic with crypto
and ace the bat hound would you read
that because i
absolutely would that sounds amazing but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop
a like and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
you